[Music]
in permanent mistake news oh my god me
permanent mistake oh you're not mistake
mistake I am a living version of it oh
you are accidente no I was oh I probably
was too so high five my parents were
like well we were gonna have you
eventually you just spread it along
there they say you spend it alone you
ask my mom was 22 they had only been
dating well they've been dead for three
years and I was like I got [ __ ] to do it
was your dad like oh man come on it's
not gonna happen don't worry about it
don't worry about it my sperm is very
fertile is your mom like more like a
best friend then she know she cuz her
mom acted like that so her mom had her
when she was 22 and like it was actually
a chain like where was like 22 22 22 and
I broke the chain but so my grandma
always tried to act like cool bestfriend
mom and my mom hated that girls yeah and
so my mom was like dogs or why you suck
dick like my mom is my daughter really
Wow
you said you feel like your mom is your
daughter she's a child
I [ __ ] elevated like a [ __ ] I
didn't realize what a monkey she was
damn she's like did you know the other
day I just realized that everybody has
different perspectives I'm like [ __ ] we
can't just realize that [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
I'm like you are dumb dude
like mom I love you but God he's so dumb
she's like we all have different troops
stop stuff let me show you something
energy cool elite nostrils she's like I
feel like there's a whole world for me
to experience and I don't even know
about it yet Mike what the [ __ ] drug
gene she had a sit-down with me one time
and she's like I understand addiction
and I'm like really and she's like I'm
addicted to matcha tea yeah love
caffeine she's like I can't go a day
without care scratching it in that [ __ ]
will go off and talk about something
else
all right submitted by Ola JK news a man
were circumcised by mistake after a
patient mix-up give me that [ __ ]
foreskin [ __ ] what if he was already
circumcised what would they have taken
off oh wow that would be stupid what the
doctors would be like yeah yeah so I
guess he had a similar name to another
patient Oh God I've been there the
previous September so they got confused
and this guy was supposed to have a
bladder inspection with a camera and
instead he woke up with his foreskin
removed I wonder what they do at the
Vietnamese hospital when everybody got
the same name see this frickin Hospital
so this error was one of eight never
events at the University Hospital of lay
Chester NHS justice Dale it's in the UK
I don't know what it's actually
pronounced like but the never events
were events that had happened at the
a hospital that they were supposed to
learn from so to never happen again
there's an eighth one there's eight yeah
and they needed that the trust had
failed to learn from all of these
mistakes made by the doctor there loves
to circumcise he's like can't wait tell
me what the next carry you through a
dollar for your foreskin
was he devastated like I was keeping
that I think he was just more like
confused and pissed off and I don't know
it doesn't really say his emotions after
the fact other it just says it was
[ __ ] sucks it was like brain surgery
or something totally different
they okay so another weather never
events where it was in April another
patient had surgery intended for another
man under the with a similar name and
one person had a hit plant implants in
the wrong side everybody leaves with the
circumcised I really get the free circum
girl it doesn't matter because you get
an extra liver and a circumcision
complimentary he left a cotton swab
inside of a child's after nasal
surgeries I heard that was common
leaving instruments and things inside
your body yeah a surgeon left a sponge
in a dude because he went on a dinner
break and he forgot he left his sponge
in a person but and so that guy like had
a greasing amount of pain until you went
on a dinner break that's crazy like
you're like cutting a [ __ ] I
agree man yeah this is my lunch time it
makes a pot pie and [ __ ] goes back yeah
yeah so they they said they're committed
to learning and improving and I'm sure
you know this work into their clinical
priorities within their quality strategy
for 2019 slash 20 since now I can't wait
till robots take over the health care
system because Fox humans are dog
robots boo like have a spasm like an
electrical and it's like you know why
he's okay
once in a while they probably won't [ __ ]
up eight times right okay
they could also hack robots and like
then they blame the robots and there's
no human accountable yeah that's okay
we'll talk to Interpol about naughty
dude I don't know I just for some reason
I feel like robots would handle it with
better care because they don't get
sleepy they don't have problems out they
don't take dinner breaks they don't take
dinner breaks they don't you know robots
it could still be programmed to do the
wrong procedure by a human yeah but I'll
wait until it's real good all the beta
testing is done yeah you're not gonna
buy an iPhone one nope you know wait I'm
alright
all the adventurous people spend the
most expensive money and do all that and
then I go okay I don't heal as fast as I
do when I was a kid I feel like one kid
I healed a lot faster your cells
actually do reproduce faster when you're
a child so they repair injuries about
Santa's face yeah looks like it
nothing's yeah it's like in under a week
you look at your crazy scab I was like
acupuncture me yeah thank us 100% now
yeah cuz I like my I feel like I'm sore
a lot longer than I should be yeah like
that yeah you're old
why is that just age male um what you're
saying your cells don't repair as well
also you have bone deterioration as you
get older your joints to Terry for sure
I see terior eating so that you're
closer to a pile of dirt by the time you
die can't wait till I'm a loose skin bag
but the hospital says it's really sorry
eight times but no they said they're
deeply and genuinely sorry they have do
you think they have slot machines in Las
Vegas hospitals no that's a good
question maybe because they have it at
gas stations liquor stores 7-eleven
it's like by the cafeteria oh I'll be so
tired there is the waiting room sucks at
a hospital if I got like some pneumonia
or some [ __ ] or a broken arm and I'm
just sitting there the waiting room at
the hospital is worse than actually
getting in we gotta bring your Nintendo
switch but if you can gamble in the
waiting room while you're crying lose
all your money before you lose the money
on the hospital bills waiting room at
the Eeyore's do you think you would take
your hospital bill and be like double or
nothing oh that's a good gamble for
everyone yeah oh my god spittle you love
like you feel like I'm gonna get better
yeah it's a place of healing yeah I
don't know yeah I feel like that smell
the smell of a hospital smells like this
it's like formaldehyde if you got bit by
a [ __ ] rattlesnake and then you
finally get into the hospital
don't you feel relief like oh hell yeah
but I wouldn't love it that's the
feeling of love yeah I love my bed no
cause like when you got pneumonia and
you can't breathe and [ __ ] and you're
walking through that Lobby you're gonna
be like save me doctor I'm sure not the
hospital but the the placebo effect is
so strong for me like if I eat like I
left him coughing them up all this
phlegm and I feel like [ __ ] I go into
urgent care or any hospital or doctor's
office and I'm like oh [ __ ] I feel like
I'm better already and by the time the
doctor sees me he's like so what are you
in here for I'm like honestly I don't
know I could've swore I was coughing let
me see you coughing me so much money you
just go to a hospital lobby just to feel
healthier and then go back home I've
done that all right go ahead Simon we
actually feel better I'm not even see
the doctor play as soon as I leave then
it goes back to normal
when I was in college and I had the
student health insurance I was going to
the clinic all that they started to know
me on a first-name basis they're like oh
it's Ricky what did you have any little
thing it's like I'm gonna just take
advantage of this like they gave me a
bag of condoms yeah every time they
always mine is I forget my ailment after
they weigh me I'm like oh [ __ ] I gained
how many pounds and then
care while I was there I'm like I'm so
depressed [ __ ]
wonderful well the hospital anyway you
would [ __ ] they're like we'll get on the
scale they hold on so I'm not naked
though I got a sweater I got shoes I
always keep all of it on and then I
subtract like ten pounds and I will last
probably 10 pounds what do you care you
know I know the scales is 280 pounds but
just to let you know even though I did
take off this close I'm still fat as
[ __ ] when I when I put on the gown I
feel like a baby I hate it
well you like your salad toss I don't
like em any good I didn't know that back
then no one did check you two for your
hernia they go all my hernia but if you
have a hernia are something for dude
making all of that balls of crap you do
what are they doing and the testicular
cancer checkup - right like where they
do that you know when I got that [ __ ]
done the guy was like super
uncomfortable and then it was making me
uncomfortable I was like Dawg you're
supposed to be the one that's like chill
about it and put me at yeah it's like am
I the thousandth ball or does my balls
just look weird no no the way he was
doing it he like seemed awkward about it
only because he liked it then yeah a gay
doctor baby yeah he has the biggest
balls I've ever seen in my life like I
didn't even think they were real I
thought you got ball implants I was like
these are so huge like how big they're
huge
I don't want to show you [ __ ] a
donkey because they bust huge loads poor
all over the floor there's a sizzle with
Monster Energy nah probably that's it
just evaporates because it's pushing on
firing the toxins is taught
[Music]
[Music]